be careful I don't know about you I'm
second of all let's just have the
conversation on the show Alissa was like
Hey I want to talk to you about
something after a few DRS something
promise you won't get mad and I was like
oh my God
P what you want to just start bragging
oh my God I can drink so much we get it
bro no it's not even so it's not even a
drink you're not even done with that
drink it didn't start to hit you yet it
did how you going to tell me what it did
it my hey my hey hey hey my bad all
right it started hit you too you
actually different no yes you are I'm
not you are okay I'm Different a little
bit you
are and it's because I'm sensitive that
I can tell the difference no you're not
sensitive at all you think you are no
I'm actually very sensitive okay how you
tell me I'm not sensitive cuz I I work
with you I work with you there's a lot
of [__] that you think you're sensitive
about and you're not we a bunch of when
I say we it's a bunch of us it's a bunch
of people that work with you we think
you're autistic because you're not so
much sensitive and it's fine it's okay
okay we accept you as such but no
there's a lot of things that you're not
sensitive about and the drinking thing
okay so let me ask you what do you
define as sensitive just make sure we're
talking about the same it could it could
be a lot of things but okay you say I'm
not sensitive so what is it do you think
I'm lacking uh [__] that's a whole other
video uh I think you're you're good at
certain things like age and stuff like
that but when we talk about feeling and
stuff like that you can sense that
something is weird or change but you can
not really pinpoint what it is for so
you could you can sense that I change
but you're going to link it to the aqua
when it's not necessarily that you can
sense some things but not really good at
sometimes sensing exactly what it is
you're not good at that sensitive means
that you're able to perceive the changes
in things so it can be the exctly so I
can sense I'm sensitive in that I can
sense the change in you yeah but you you
OB you are you going to you link it to
that and you're going to be like yeah
it's it's because of that but that's not
a matter of being sensitive that's a
matter of being having the awareness to
know what it is that's causing that
that's a different thing and and what
did you say you said you said it started
to hit you and that's exactly what we're
talking about okay so if you want fire
say your behavior changed that would be
accurate yes okay that's not what you
said hold up if I say it's because that
that is because my reasoning is off as
to the reason why does not mean I'm not
sensitive ex exactly you're okay your
reasoning is off okay that's fine
because you're not that kind of all I
the only claim I made okay excuse me the
only CLA
the reing off I never disagreed I never
disagreed I'm not saying you disagreed I
just said you you you did just saying
read all no no that's what you said your
claim was I'm not sensitive not I highly
disagree you're not sensitive to knowing
what is the link
with you just changed the word no you
just change the word yo every time we
have this conversation you always keep
doing this Ethiopian dance whenever we
it is I'm I'm sry hold
up yo yo I'm sensitive no you're not
sensitive to the fact that you are
unaware of Oh my days Oh my days is a is
a kind of sensitivity can we not agree
that it's a kind of no okay we don't
agree it's
different my God the ability to perceive
the motivations of why people do certain
things is a very different skill set
than being sensitive for example I'm so
sensitive I can tell someone's behind me
and they're looking at me a certain type
of I might not be able to tell why
that's a different skill than being able
to sense that you're right okay so I'm
just talking about sensitivity you're
right that's it no I said you're I don't
disagree I said you're right okay list
see three times yo you can't disagree
with an hour I can do whatever the can't
disagree I can do you can't disagree
with me for an hour and I'll be like
whoa and you like all right I'm good I'm
done I could do whatever the [__] I want
but I'm not done so I want to keep going
and but keep on going but I'm done no no
no
let me finish this don't cut me off I'm
going do whatever the [__] I
want [__] you cut me off all the time I
can't do that I'mma cut you off I just
did that was so childish that was so
child all all this to okay so you're
about to CH all this to say I'm very
sensitive in fact I would say I am
incredibly sensitive incredibly yeah I
think I'm so oh my God I'm serious I'm
serious